all right let's get into audience
questions for the week of course you can
send them in however you want email
voicemail Twitter reddit whatever you
want today's first question is via
voicemail the voicemail number is two
one nine two david p hey david i wanted
to ask you about the Laffer curve I hear
a lot of people on the Left often when
putting the idea of the Laffer curve
because it seems to be associated with
Reaganomics and the extent to which that
it is you know I can understand this
kind of criticism but I just want to
hear from you in theory why the idea is
not sound because my understanding of it
is that at a zero percent tax rate the
government will take in zero dollars in
revenue obviously at a hundred percent
tax rate the government will take in
zero percent revenue because they will
completely destroy any kind of
productivity so all to my mind the
Laffer curve says you correct me if I'm
wrong is that there's just a number
somewhere in between 0 and 100 that's
optimal obviously people on the right
will tend to say that that's a lower
number and use this idea as a
justification to reduce tax rates but I
don't understand why I'm theory and
liberals could very easily apply the lab
refer to and say the ideal tax rate is
actually higher so I don't understand
why the lapper curve is kind of always
associated with the political right in
this country when it seems to me that
it's sort of a neutral thing that either
side could use and it seems like sort of
a common-sense idea so I'd like to hear
your take on this thanks David
yeah so listen the the right uses the
Laffer curve because they like to come
up with just really simple ways of doing
politics like they've been really
successful by saying hey taxes or taxes
are bad because it's your money you've
earned it and you should get to keep it
so taxes should be really low or
abortion is bad because you're killing a
kid that's it and they really like these
simple ideas so the Laffer curve has
been used almost exclusively by the
right to justify cutting taxes you're
right it could hypothetically be used by
the left but it's not because the left
tends to take a more nuanced view on
this and I'll explain what I mean
so yes the Laffer curve is the idea that
given some tax rate
between 0% and a hundred percent there
is some optimal optimal number but more
importantly and this is where the right
tends to use it they often like to argue
that a reduction in the tax rate can
lead to an increase in government
revenue that basically the idea would be
if you sometimes lower the tax rate
typically that's what the right wants to
do you will generate more total revenue
by more people working because the tax
rate on their income is lower and
because there will be more money
floating around for economic growth here
are the problems with the Laffer curve
number one it's usually used to justify
a reduction in taxes when actually an
increase in taxes would be better for
the economy so the Laffer curve is
constantly misused by the right but the
most important thing is that the tax
rate that the Laffer curve is referring
to is like an overall rate or an average
rate of some kind and as we know we have
a progressive tax system so the impact
that a change in the tax rate is going
to have on government revenue is going
to be very different based on who is
getting the tax increase or the tax
decrease you could have a decrease or an
increase to the average tax rate in a
way that would be stimulative to the
economy or not if you give all if you
decrease taxes by reducing the tax rate
only on the richest Americans your
economic benefit is going to be far
smaller than if you lower the average
tax rate by giving money back to
middle-class Americans because
middle-class Americans need the extra
money for their daily lives whereas the
very rich are just going to save that
money which is not very economically
stimulative so that's why the right Pat
likes to oversimplify a lot of issues
and they say hey the Laffer curve tells
us you lower taxes revenue goes up the
average tax rate that the Laffer curve
deals with does not actually tell us
anything about what would happen to the
economy which tax bracket are you
talking about yeah this is what
Republicans are trying to argue now
right with their tax plan yeah you know
even though revenues will go
we'll make up for it because there'll be
so much more economic productivity
indeed but then you have independent
agencies analyzing it and they predict
maybe a tenth of the economic output
that Republicans are predicting that's
exactly right and you could have this is
not what people I think don't understand
is we're not making an argument for or
against raising or lowering taxes on any
particular tax bracket in this segment
what I'm telling you is that the Laffer
curve is effectively useless if we're
talking about the average tax rate
because we have a progressive tax system
in the US with brackets and it's almost
always misused by the right just to
justify lowering taxes all the time
which is exactly what they want to do so
yes Laffer curve it's interesting it's
not particularly useful to us to in
thinking about what it is we need to do
with tax ball yeah I love it zero to 100
percent somewhere in the middle of there
but it tells us nothing about where the
top of that parabola is like where does
it max out and not to mention what the
brackets should be and at what income
limits you go from from being in one
bracket to the other which are really
the most important thing so you it's
interesting to know about the Laffer
curve I don't know how much it's gonna
teach you about what taxes should be